GES TO AHE SELEC
IG
NECESSARY.
>> PDE SUMMONED TH AEM THE MOB D
THE FLAME OF THIS ATTACK
OVERTHROW, PUT DN,BY, THE GOVER
UNITED STATES.
AUTHORITY THER.TTCHAIR LI
CHENEY SAID THOSE  PLOT
WHAT SHE CALLED AN OPRESIDTIIO
PRIOR TO THE PCEEDINGS,
TO WATCH THE
HEINE ONLY
R COUNT PIFF BO R M EM
AGAINST THEM.
HEARING LAIGW RE
THAN 20 MILLION VIEWERS, IN
SHOR LOT AND W
ABT THE IMPACT AND ALLHE
QUESONT RA
WE BEGIN, THOUGH A
QUESTION WE ADANW IS THE FORMER
HANDLING BEING ACCUSED O T GREA
Y S
THE ANSWER?
LASHG ITD ONE-TIME WHITE HOU
HERE IS WHAT SHE TOLD THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THEN ATTORNEL BS
THAT HIS'S ELEAIMS WERE  DIDT AU
PERSPECTIVE T THTTORNEY R MADE
THATY PERSPECTIVE.
BARR.EPTED WHATS SAYING
SO HERE'S HOW THE
SO  TODAY ON HIS
IVANKA TRUMP WAS NOT INVOLVED IN
LOOKINATCTION S.
SHE HANG SINCECK
WAS,MY
TR
BARR A HIS POSITIOAS
ATTORNEY.
I NTK COLLINS ONG OF THE
WHITE USN
STANDARDS, DOES ISE YOU
THE FORMER PREE
WING SHADE AS
OWN DAUGHTERr: I THINK IT'S A Y
MA PE THATERE CERT
CERA HIS ORBIT, SECRETARIES OF
TO SEE HIM DO ITH HIS  PUT THE
HE IS DOODAY AFTERT AFTER SEEINR
TESTIMONY WHICH WAS, YOU KNOW,
ND MOS
E AR
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FORMER
PRESIDENUMD
THENNEY GELY SOURED BECAUSE HE
WOEN IF HE WT BE
PUBLIC ABOUT THAT ACTING NOW AS
OUT, TRY DISMISS HIS OWNDAUGHT'
WAG INSIDETE ARGUING SHE CHE
OUT I SHOULD R
FROM HIS DAUGHTEERY LY.DEA THIS
>> IT DOES LEAVE THE
IS THERE MORE THERE?
HOW DOES WHAT IVANKA TRUMP TOLD
E COMMITTEE THAT SHE ACCTEBILL
WI ELECTION FRAUSQ
AND SAYIN E DAYS AND WEEKS
TEELECTION?
>> Reporter: WELL WE'VE ER
ME SHE WAS U
PEOPLE TO KEEP UP THE T, F
FACT IT WAS BECOMILECLEARER BY
PRT TRUMP HAN
ELECTION BUT THE IDET ANNOALLY
INVOLVED DOESN'TLL
WIUR REPORTING BECAUSE
OBVIY ERE UNTIL
THE OUER EXITINGTHE WHITHO FORME
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE DAY OF
TALKING ABOUTN'S INAUGURATION,t
E OFHAACTUALLY KNEW ABOUT WHAT S
PROOFS
IO DADDY O
A GUWHAT WAS
G , ON JANUARY 6th, SHE
WAS ER WHITE
D  WHAT,R WHO BETTLD
INNUFOR OW
HIS DAUGHTER CHECKED OUT
FATHER.
DAUGHTERS
THEIR FATHERS ARE DOING,  THERE
RESHIP.
>> Reporter: AND IT CERTAINLY
WAS A ST
IS A CLOSE RELATIONSHIP.
THE DAY OF JANUARY 6th, WE VHO
WANTED TO GO INTE OVAL
OFFICE ANDPEH TRTH
DAAS SOMNGITASING ON, A LOT OF
INCLUDING TOT TO PRESIDENT TRUMA
OFF HIELL TH
Y VIEAVE THEPISHE WAS SOMEBODY E
TESTIFIED HE ABOUT
W TENACIOUG IN
E AN HER F
OR WASN'T CLOSELY RELA L
WHAT WAS GOING ON THAT DAY AND
THSE COMING OU T
E ISBV JUST
DIVORCE FROM REALITY.
D NOTE, SHE DNIFY FOR ABOUT
TH COMMITTEE AND TRUMPSHINGTON Y
GANKP AND JARED
KUSHNER HI TO GON
N' TO GO UNDER
SUBPOENA, DIDN'T WANA
ION LIARROSO THE IN AND
THLE ASPECSEEING TRUMP COME OUT
DISMISS HER AND TRSTANCE BETWEE
SURPRISING BUT NOT REALLTH
OF COURSE, IT'
SOMETHING HE'S DON. DOES SPEA L
HE'LL GO TO TOO EXPLAIN  HAPPEN
>> AS YOU KAI
THE QUON ELSE DID ANE OF HNT
H HER FATHER.LLS,MUCH BEING WIT.
MON THE LARGER WHAT'S
NEXTATED LEGAL TRUMP
IF YOU ARE ANING WHAT YOU E ANTO
WEEK, WHAT THROUGH YOU Y'R
Y CLOSELY. WATERGATE ANALOGY,
ARCHIBALD CKCAME SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR BY THE TIME I
T GOORY. THEY WOULD
TTENERAL A VECLOSY CAN HA
IMPLICATIONS ON AN TRIALTEINDIC
THEY'RE PAYING C ATTENTION.
M,O
E WATCR THE POSSIBLE CRIMES TH
COMMITBEES ATTORNE
GEL GARLAND ED FIB PR OPINION A
S FOR HAVING ME
BAD ALWA, WONDL E
OTHERD TO ASK
TLE DIERY
J
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL
WT DO THESE TWOET
?
TFIEN
INSEEAA FEDERAO MMITTED
DE
OBSTIOS, THAT'S SC
UP T HEARINGS, THEON
ELECTORS OD
CONSPIRACYO E UNITEDATES AND TH
SEVENT  THA OUT.K THERE WAS
EVIDENCE.HY IT WAS SA
D ES
NUMBER ONE WAS BILL BARRER
WAKA TRUMPKNE HASTWAS CORRAN
Y, WITGIA  REPORTS, S, RAFFENSP
TAPEECJOST 780 VOSO
>> SO JO A
PEOPLE ION ROAD MAP PUT FORWARB?
>> THEWOT RE O
IS DUSIVELY T THCO
EY THEIR ORAND RY, COLLECT THEI
EV
I THINK THEY AREG
THEIR OW